Democrats and Republicans alike have
jumped on the "break 'em up" bandwagon,
embracing antitrust solutions to rein in
the behavior of technology giants.
These would-be trust-busters claim that Big
Tech companies like Google, Amazon,
and Facebook crush startups and shut out
innovation. But do these activists need a reality check?
For instance, Amazon
controls just 5% of the US retail market
and Amazon also does exactly what
Democrats like Bernie Sanders and
Chuck Schumer want Corporate America
to do more of: foregoing stock buybacks
to invest massively in R & D. And it's not just
Amazon — the top five US corporate R & D investors
are all Big Tech companies. But ask
yourself — would these companies spend
nearly as much if they had to shut down or
split off as much as half of their business?
And might banning new Big Tech
acquisitions deny a crucial off-ramp to
those who invest early in promising
startups? With all public policy decisions,
there are trade-offs and
unintended consequences to consider.
When it comes to breaking up Big Tech,
we risk stifling America's most
innovative and promising sector.
What do you think about breaking up Big Tech?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.